(truck rumbling)
- [Narrator] After months
of bloody fighting,
Ukrainian soldiers at the
besieged Azovstal Steel plant
laid down their arms
and started being evacuated by
Russian forces as prisoners,
apparently ceding control of Mariupol.
(Volodymyr speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Soldiers
being carried out to buses
could be seen in footage shared
by local authorities and Russian media
after Russia announced an agreement
for the wounded to leave.
The site was the final holdout
of Ukrainian soldiers who had
resisted Russia's occupation
of the strategic port city,
even after Moscow declared control
over Mariupol in late April.
Here's how Azovstal,
where hundreds of civilians
had also taken refuge
for weeks, became one of
the most dramatic battles
in the war, and captured
the world's attention.
As the Russian army turned
Mariupol into rubble
over the course of three months,
it failed to quickly
seize the Azovstal plant.
In a televised address last month,
Putin ordered his troops to
temporarily pause the attacks
and secure the area.
(Vladimir speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The site is
a Cold War era labyrinth
of warehouses, tunnels and rail tracks,
spanning a territory of foursquare miles.
Alongside the Azovstal fighters,
hundreds of civilians got trapped.
Throughout the siege, the
Ukrainian soldiers posted videos
of the dire situation online,
showing children and women,
as well as the conditions they lived in,
and calling for help.
(Serhiy speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] In early May,
the fighters said they were
let down by politicians
and criticized Kyiv for abandoning them.
(Sviatoslav speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The Ukrainian president
had called on Russia to release
or exchange those remaining at Azovstal.
These pleas and the worsening
humanitarian situation there
got the world's attention.
In late April, the UN
Secretary General met
with the Russian president
and asked to set up civilian
evacuations from Azovstal.
Following the visit,
hundreds of people were escorted out
via a United Nations brokered
humanitarian corridor.
But the fighters stayed on
despite dwindling prospects
of a victory.
The wives, girlfriends, and mothers
of the Azovstal forces
lobbied for their rescue.
Some embarked on an international tour,
including a visit to the pope.
- You are our last hope.
We hope you can save their lives.
Please don't let them down.
- [Narrator] On Monday,
Ukraine said about 260 fighters
were taken to Russian-held areas
and that they will be exchanged
for captured Russian soldiers
while efforts continue to
evacuate remaining defenders.
The Kremlin said the
soldiers would be treated
in accordance with
international standards.
The end of the battle for Mariupol
is likely to be viewed as
a major victory in Moscow
but Kyiv also called
it mission accomplished
as a prolonged resistance
helped the Ukrainian army
to organize its resources.
(Hanna speaking in foreign language)
(pensive music)